first with the other I don't know how
much information the showrunners have
given you in terms of what the other
really is but as the actor playing the
other how are you kind of approaching
that in a term in terms of a way of like
justifying what it actually does yeah so
I didn't want to do like um something
like a dissociative State I don't want
to encroach on an actual disorder that
you know I don't know anything about and
I don't think that's what this is um
without saying there's something
Supernatural because I don't know if
there is either like quite honestly I
think it's interpretive but um there I
didn't really have anything to draw on
for the other Taissa so it was a lot of
conversations with the create with
Ashley and Bard and Jonathan and uh
really discussing the the bits and
pieces of what makes up the other taisa
is she feral is she nice does she does
she does she hate our say you know she
seems to hate artisa but um we discussed
all these things and then it was really
just like play it was like being a child
and playing dress-up and saying you know
here's a fun thing I can do
and yeah all season one my thing has
been there's no snooper natural it's
just like true human Horrors coming out
and making all this happen the more I
watch of season two the harder and
harder I'm having justifying that idea
that I know
um Juliet For You episode five the
moment where um where she accesses her
her past with with lottie's help
why do you think after the overdose she
chose to completely block out
information that she knew she needed and
do you think there's any other character
on the show that could have helped her
re-access that information other than
Lottie I hate to give you such a boring
answer I have no idea
I I just when when nothing else I commit
and I commit uh I just full on
um I don't know why I don't even know
why that's the one thing that's
hurting her the most or how she denied
it I don't know but you know they
hopefully it works it talks more
compelling I agree yeah everything in
the show is filled with subtext and just
keeps the wheels in my head turning
Non-Stop and now that leads me to your
last shot that I saw in episode six when
she finally sees the group reuniting I'm
obsessed with reaction shots in this
show because sometimes those say more
than even dialogue heavy beats so what
did you want to convey in that
particular shot where it's so important
to convey how she feels about the group
reunited I haven't seen the shot you're
talking about so what we lived it yeah
and so we haven't like
yeah yeah no I know I know the moment
you're talking about but I haven't seen
how it's all put together but even when
you just said it I got a little bit of a
shiver because it was the first time we
were all coming together to work and
play to in in the world of Lottie like I
hadn't worked with Tony so and or Lauren
um or Melanie uh Christina and I had
done a couple of scenes and then I'd
just been working with Juliet so it
there was this moment that and they had
a big Crane and and there's Lottie and
she turns and I see them all and I get
the joy of seeing each individual face
for the first time in their characters
because we shot that scene first and I
did get Shivers and then I had to walk
slowly across and even just seeing
Lauren's face and I felt it there were
all the feelings going on
and it was kind of amazing and we did it
a few times but again and just even
looking at time because I hadn't seen
her characters so broken and disheveled
as well and so seeing that for the first
time was really
and and then from there the show just
goes and goes and goes and we're all
together and these women actually belong
together and it's it's terrifying this
is a killer moment to cut off our
screeners that hurt that hurt to have a
stock there I'll end with a question for
all three of you I love talking about
the value of a good seeing partner so in
these six episodes of season two can you
each name a time when a scene partner
was was just the partner you needed and
they helped you access something in your
own character that you wouldn't have
been able to without them we got to do
so many things together yeah all the
time yeah I'm always leaning in to who
I'm playing with and yeah and it's quite
easy I mean it's easy with this one I've
had moments where it was difficult if
someone's not fully present or but uh
yeah we kept pushing it and reshaping it
and we especially in five two I think
there's this scene where we we go each
other and it was so proud Primal and it
was just like I know she's got me and I
feel safe working with her and she knows
I've got her and so we would do things
like she was incredible she fell on the
ground and she was just heaving yeah
remember that and I was like me as a
mother I wanted to like comfort her and
I was and we you just go through
something else because you were so safe
in it I was fully in at that time in in
the season as well I was like going for
it and Julia and I found things we even
had one moment it would be really
intimate in space and that's quite
unique you can't always space in bed and
I love I like yeah at least that's our
the kid history of the woods I feel like
they had a cross definitely I um
quickly I mean I loved working with
Lauren she was a great scene partner
um obviously and it was I get so lucky
with team partners on this show but I I
do have to give it to Rukia who plays
Simone my wife
um I worked with her so much in season
one
um that we I just have such a deep love
for her it's ridiculous
um I cry when I see her
um so yeah what what the other Ty winds
up doing to Simone is truly
heartbreaking and that took very little
acting I I did not want to say goodbye
to Rukia not to say that we do say
goodbye to Ikea but I need more you guys
crush it this season it's not easy to
keep the bar as high as you said it in
season one but you very much do here
thank you so much
Moodle